Hello.
Today, we're going to smash an Apple.
Not Apple golf again.
No,
an apple.
Now before everyone goes mental,
this is actually a really old
Power Book G4 that doesn't work,
so, I settled that.
Hopefully I'll connect to something.
What's that?
That's the DVI.
What is that?
What?
Do you want to do this one?
I will, actually.
Thanks.
I've had enough of smashed apples.
Bloody yeah.
Yeah.
It is heavy isn't it?
Oooh!
Okay.
Let me walk you through our
path of destruction here.
The keyboard was actually quite resilient.
Most of the keys stayed on.
You got some of that.
That's good. Yeah.
Do you think they still work?
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah.
Yeah?
Here's the top.
Slightly bent.
You could probably ah
Buff it out.
pay someone to buff it out yeah.
Get a little hammer.
Tap it out.
Now, interestingly,
There's a J,
written in pen
on the inside.
I'm not sure who wrote that.
If you wrote it,
give us a bell. You know.
Yeah
let us know.
Let us know if that was you.
All right then.
Here's the screen.
Remember at school when
the teacher had those like transparencies
for the overhead projector?
Looks like a load of them.
I'm pretty sure that's glass.
Nice sheen.
Oh really?
I'm sorry Steve Jobs,
I love you.
Aww.
Well that was a rather violent end
for an old Mac.
Probably could still sell that
for a couple hundred quid.
Yeah.
Ebay?
Do it.
Who wants it?
Anyone?
Place your bids below.
I'm only kidding. Don't do that.
I'm not gonna look.
Check back tomorrow.